but my real question is everybody's
really talking about how Twitter's in
trouble could Twitter become MySpace yes
that's scary for Twitter well is scary
for me too I'm gotten used to getting my
news from Twitter great people used to
get their news from the radio
thanks right right I was used to getting
my music from MTV so we just got a
realign and get our news from snapchat
or Instagram yep okay what is in trouble
[ __ ]
and by the way Twitter is the reason I'm
even sitting here as you know Twitter
was the first time I really popped back
in the day I was doing my wine show I
jumped on Twitter I thought it was gonna
be big it was in a being way bigger and
and I really popped in transition in the
business contents at a wine content and
so I love Twitter Twitter's like the
first girl I ever hooked up with you
know what I mean there's that always
that peace in my soul and so it makes
it's hard for me to say that by the way
I sit on a lot of Twitter stock I sold a
lot of it but I still have a lot I have
a lot of economics they got a change you
got involved like Madonna did it right
she reinvented herself 14 times that's
why she had a long career you know like
you've got to reinvent yourself you need
prop Twitter didn't make product changes
for six years in its prime yeah you know
so I let's talk about sports when you're
the best athlete and you're like the guy
and you're like one of top 15 players
basketball look at a dunk you know at
danke Ansari I'll give you some love
he's got one of the big basketball count
so I'm thinking about that I think about
basketball players draymond Green he's
my buddy
dreama really worked on his game every
offseason you know uh Ricky Rubio the
flashy point guard from Minnesota if he
developed his outside shot he would have
been a much bigger player he had all the
passing skills the quickness he's got
everything if instead of going to Ibiza
and [ __ ] chicks in the offseason he
worked on his 18-foot jumper he'd be in
the game
Twitter was banging chicks in the summer
got it
[Music]